on l'attendait depuis longtemps l'été
est enfin arrivé à oui il ya des
endroits que j'ai un stand était par
contre tout à fait réglé quoi qu'il en
soit on va être prêt protégez-vous
publie dans son numéro de juillet une
trousse pratique pour nous aider à
affronter la canicule beaucoup à
refroidir la maison bonjour mathilde
droit
bon vous êtes pencher là dessus parce
que effectivement il ya plusieurs choses
qui s'en viennent quand ça va réchauffer
moyo les écrans solaires on va se
concentrer sur les maisons là qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve dans protégez-vous
là-dessus possible oui on a préparé un
dossier qui regroupe tous nos meilleurs
conseils pour vous aider à préparer
votre logement ou votre maison en vue
des prochaines vagues de chaleur et donc
ce dossier-là comprend d'abord un guide
d'achat de climatiseurs et de
ventilateurs un tableau comparatif de 25
climatiseurs de fenêtres et portatifs et
également des stratégies complémentaires
pour adapter votre habitation on veut
déjà mais qu'est ce que c'est la
meilleure façon pour réfléchir la maison
la climatisation ça reste la seule
vraiment solution efficace pour
rafraîchir la maison s'en sort pas si
c'est vrai que ça peut paraître un
discours un peu contradictoires pour
certaines personnes parce que les
climatiseurs ont un impact sur
l'environnement on parle d'urgence
climatique
actuellement ça reste que selon les
experts qu'on a consulté l'impact est
moindre au québec qu'ailleurs puisque on
utilise l'hydroélectricité qui est une
énergie propre bon vous en avez magazine
et j'ai vu en fin de semaine je me
promenais dans les grandes surfaces on
les voit toutes alignées on se dit oh mi
juillet ça va être le stampede la course
pour en acheter
oui d'ailleurs c'est le bon moment si
vous avez à vous équiper comment faire
regarder dès maintenant parce que si
vous attendez trop longtemps dans les
pays restera plus grand chose dans les
magasins donc première peut-être chose à
regarder est ce que vous voulez vous
tourner vers un climatiseur portatif ou
de fenêtre nous ce que notre guide
d'achat conclut c'est que les
les climatiseurs de fenêtres sont plus
efficaces sont aussi plus abordable
ceci dit si les modèle portatif peuvent
être une bonne option
d'abord il convient à tous les types de
fenêtres que ce soit à guillotine
coulissante à manivelle
si vous êtes locataire et que votre
propriétaire vous donne pas le droit
d'installer un climatisateur fenêtre
mais là c'est une bonne idée de se
tourner vers ce modèle et les plus
efficaces celui qu'on place dans la
fenêtre
oui il va être plus efficace et donc
j'ai l'air de l'extérieur à l'intérieur
et vice versa bon les ventilateurs
sociaux en attendant sa norme est de
faire bouger l'air
c'est un bon rendement mais c'est sûr
que c'est une solution qui est moins
efficace que la climatisation mais si
vous avez un budget qui limite et que
vous ne voulez pas vous lancer dans
l'installation d'un climatiseur ça peut
être effectivement une bonne option il
en existe différents modèles sur le
marché que ce soit l'appareil de table
sur pieds à tours de pales
mais le plus efficace sûr et le
ventilateur de plafond
c'est le seul d'ailleurs tu peux avoir
la certification energy star donc c'est
le plus écoénergétique
le seul bémol par contre c'est que selon
la loi il faudrait le faire installer
par un électricien
bon c'est faire ce qu'il fait descendre
leur show effectivement donc ceci
pourrait la différence est pas un et
ferment de notables mais ça pourrait
être une bonne option de se tourner vers
alors parlé d' ou de l'un des autres
solutions qui sont possibles
effectivement mais on a on a
on vous donne plusieurs conseils sur
améliorer si c'est possible le plus
possible votre l'efficacité énergétique
de votre maison
plus votre maison est bien isolée plus
vous allez garder la chaleur à
l'intérieur longtemps l'été vous pouvez
aussi bloqué le soleil de l'extérieur de
la première heure du jour que ce soit
avec un auvent des volets ça va être
plus efficace que si vous mettez
simplement des rideaux parce que les
rideaux vont devenir chaud à l'intérieur
ils vont donc faire augmenter la
température intérieure
il existe sur le marché des stores des
toiles qui vont refléter les rayons de
soleil même des pellicules qu'on peut
coller sur sur les fenêtres donc ça peut
aider à garder un peu plus offrez votre
mari vous suggérez vous à l'extérieur de
la maison c'est vraiment ce qui pourrait
être l'objet se réchauffe
effectivement on voit beaucoup ça on
note d'ailleurs les volets lycée pour
c'est pour cette raison mais très bien
on apprend toujours comme ça les voyages
forment la jeunesse et de garde au frais
voilà très bien merci beaucoup merci de
te voir